this is jocko podcast number 243
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
it's a different world
when you get home
i mean at some point while you're over
there
you accept death
you you give away
normal life you give away the normal
world
it's probably just a coping mechanism of
some kind
to just accept your fate
to accept your fate
that the world is war
that the world is dirt and blood and
pain
and death and you have to accept that
at least i did
then i'd be lying to you
if i said that i didn't want that
acceptance that i didn't want that
attitude
because the world
the normal world the everyday world is a
complicated
place there's all kinds of things going
on
family and friends and mortgage payments
and bills to pay and a future to worry
about and retirement
and savings and the kids
then the list goes on
but in war that's all gone
there really isn't even a future nothing
else matters
nothing but the mission and the men
that was my concern
did i think about my family
sometimes
i had other things to think about
and other things to worry about bullets
and bombs
and blood and [__] and life and death
and you go through it
you get through it
some of you do
some of you don't
and for those that do make it through
one day just as quickly
as it started it's over
get on a plane
and you fly home
back to the world
and on that flight home
i only think about one thing
that i didn't bring home all my men
and then the door
of the plane opens
and we're home
and then 24 hours of flight time
you go from ramadi iraq to san diego
california
at least physically you do
mentally it's gonna take a little bit
more time to come around
but you soon realize that you are alive
and you have a house and a wife and kids
and mortgage and a future
you are alive and you are thankful
and you want to live a life that honors
your friends that didn't come home
and then it's let's go let's get it on
let's surf and fight and drink
and eat and play guitar and run and roll
and surf some more let's go
let's do this we're lucky to even be
here
full-on
for me much of that time
the surfing and the rolling and the
eating and the drinking and the
jamming on the get box was spent with
seth stone
the delta platoon commander
he bought a house a mile away from mine
he was like an uncle to my kids part of
the family
and you know he's uh a much nicer
guy than me much friendlier than me
always made friends
[Music]
and before we left on deployment he had
somehow linked up with a guy by the name
eugene cooper legendary surfboard shaper
and seth got gene to make us some boards
[Music]
some epic boards
and when we got home we got those boards
and we rode them
and through gene seth also linked up
with a a guy named mike
black that made a surf movie
if if it can even be called that's kind
of a crazy
surf movie called invasion from planet c
the sci-fi surf movie
it was
it was unique it was
kind of wild and funny and insane and
just kind of completely crazy and
maybe that's why we liked it because it
had some good surfing and it
made us laugh
i also had some good music in it
some real good music one song in that
movie was called
mad man
it was by a band called the white
buffalo
and we heard the lyrics to the song
and they made they made sense to us
there's one section of lyrics that says
like an
animal out of his den you better hide
your money
you better hide your children you can't
keep
your fear at bay because the madman's
roaming these streets today
the madman's coming
we got that we understood what that was
all about
and the white buffalo songs were in some
other surf movies along the way
one called shelter
a song called wrong
knew some other guys in there joel tudor
was in that movie
so seth figured out where the rest of
this music came from and
we started listening to this white
buffalo
became like a little soundtrack
because the music and the lyrics and the
sound and the attitude was somehow
somehow it was about us
about what we had seen about what we had
been through
about what we were going through
i don't really i don't really remember
exactly when we went and saw the white
buffalo for the first time
i know that we saw him one time at
ucsd in some kind of cafe and there was
probably about 12 people there
so i'm at the kaz bond san diego the
belly up
a few times eventually we saw him at
bigger places
like the house of blues and the
observatory
and we knew that somehow this guy
he got us
and i remember the first time we saw him
at the casbah
it's the last time we saw him when there
was a pretty small crowd
but it was a small enough crowd that
everyone that was there
knew who he was there was no people
wandering in they knew
they knew who the white buffalo was and
they were there to see him
and people were drinking and people were
carrying on
and they were talking and laughing
and then the pa music faded
then the lights went dark
and then he walked out on stage
alone
and he played
he started strumming that guitar
[Music]
mother
i try to do right by you
to do what you asked me to
i did wrong and i knew
[Music]
mother
it was all i could do
find a way back home
make everything new
i wish true
[Music]
father
will i gave my soul to you
[Music]
i came and blindfolded for you
it was all that i knew
open your arms and i'll fly out of hell
up to you
i wish it was true
[Music]
boy come on out from the cold
lost outside there don't you know
it's not what you say it's what you do
just keep wishing your wishes are true
your dreams are reality
there's no pain there's no misery
you just polish the blood in the bruise
but i wish it was true
[Music]
country
i was a soldier for you
[Music]
i did what just me too
it was wrong and you knew
[Music]
throw me away when you're through
home of the brave and free
the red white and blue
wish it was true
then when he got done playing the place
was
silent for a second seth and i were
standing there like everybody else
then we looked at each other we smiled
the place went crazy
but we did too
was a good night
it's good memory
and memories are all i have left of seth
now
on those songs
and those are some powerful songs
and it's an honor today to have the man
behind those memories and behind those
songs the man himself a man
named jake smith otherwise known
as the white buffalo
jake thanks for coming down man
thank you for having me
no pressure on that set right there
that was intense yeah man
um tell me about it yeah it's
lots of stuff wrapped up in in the songs
that you write it's
um it's kind of crazy when i think about
all the time that i spent
sitting there listening playing them
listening to them
going to your shows uh you know just
being some random dude we almost got
into a fight at the belly up one time
some guy was talking like just just mad
dog and seth and seth
was like six two you know and
you know i mean i know i look like a
serial killer for sure
seth not quite as much because he's too
nice but still
he's a strapping dude with a shaved head
and cauliflower ears right that's
generally
not a go situation for scraps no that's
a sign
yeah so at belly up we're standing there
and this dude's kind of nudging into
seth and seth's kind of looking at him
and i'm standing
behind the guy which in the jujitsu
world means
i i can kill you you have no you have
zero chance
but it didn't happen but lots of
memories man
it's awesome it's awesome to have you
come down here i appreciate it yeah my
pleasure
uh let's let's talk a little bit about
you man enough about me i've been
talking about myself here
for a long time let's hear about you all
right
um so you were born where up in oregon i
was born in eugene oregon
and what was that all about were your
parents working up there uh my dad was
still going to school
he's a college professor and he was
um i think he was still working on his
masters at that point
and we moved down to uh he might have
been working on his phd
and then we moved down to southern
california huntington beach uh when i
was
maybe one uh-huh and he continued that
uh at pepperdine and did some student
teaching and then we were there for
maybe since i was one until 20. dang
malibu yeah we didn't live there though
oh
but he uh we lived in huntington beach
which is always it's
yeah well i think he's cool too but i
mean let's face it if you lived in
malibu and you surf malibu all the time
you probably wouldn't be here right now
i probably wouldn't you you'd be a whole
perspective
so so you you you grew up in huntington
beach then i did
and what was what was the situation your
your dad's a college professor at
pepperdine uh no my dad was a college
professor
at cal state dominguez hills oh i see so
he did he was student teaching or he
finished his
his phd there and then moved on to
cal state dominguez hills for carson
what does he teach he taught uh public
administration
his uh what even is that right now it's
tough to explain right
uh i think it's like the study of city
budgets i think a lot of policemen take
it
uh city planners it's like uh in the
political science world no what do you
think makes a man
say to themselves they're looking at the
courses and they're like there you go
public administration let's call it my
name yeah i don't know
and it it you know i mean he's
interested by some odd things like that
but i it was surprising uh not
surprising but
yeah it is it's a one of the lesser
known um
you know uh pedagogies or you know it's
not
it's not a normal when you say what that
is most people say
when i say that yeah exactly what i said
you know what about your mom what was
she up she was a nurse
she was a labor and delivery nurse oh
dang uh
brother and a sister you have a brother
and a sister correct older younger i'm
the youngest
you're the baby i'm the baby was that
whole thing work out you know that whole
that whole thing you know what i'm
talking about yeah where you're the so
now you get coddled and everything and
i mean you're the spoiled kid it was it
was part of it
definitely how far from the beach did
you live in huntington beach
um i live we used to take the bus to go
surf okay when i was young
um two miles oh that's not
that's not bad you could teach cruiser
that all day long we could but we busted
or got dropped off the bus was easier
than a beach cruiser i don't know why we
bust it you know
it's a weird uh yeah
i think it was all bmx so it just wasn't
an option to have the rack
and whatnot yeah they haven't did they
have them you had to carry it under your
arm back then
uh i don't even know if they had the
racks back then yeah now you get all
kinds of racks
you're good to go bmx or not that's true
i think they
they can uh how much were your money um
i served quite a bit but i just it
wasn't something that um
i picked up super easily it was the age
of the small
thin board oh yeah and i've always been
a big dude and and to ride
you know slater's board right i'm on a
6-3 and i'm
6-2 you know and it's like some way for
thin thing that i can't
you know i'm sitting out in the lineup
and i'm up to my tits in the water
and uh it's not gonna float me it took
me a while to just go like i mean i
should probably get a bigger board yeah
something that actually can i can paddle
in the waves yeah that's not that's a
big mental transition today
man my buddy josh hall just made me a
board that's eleven
it is the it's i it's the thickest board
i think a human could make because my
son was telling him what i wanted
and and they were doing this like as a
secret surprise for me right yeah
what's that cool secret surprise behind
my back so my son was telling him hey
you know and josh had some ideas and my
son's like no the biggest
thickest board you could possibly make
in josh hall delivered
big time you got to try that board i got
some thick boards too but i got a couple
one of mine looks like a paddle board
but it's not a board it's a it's a it's
a surfboard for a bit for a large man
right we'll say
so you uh and i know you played you were
freaking hardcore baseball player right
i was that was kind of my dream as a
child ended up playing
college baseball division one baseball
had a scholarship to play baseball what
position did you play
uh until i was a senior
in high school i played shortstop um
so i was on the more athletic side of
especially for a big man they thought i
was gonna be like uh
in the next like cal ripken like you
know and he he was you know big
that's a big statement you just made
they thought i was gonna be
the next calvary
no but that was they were grooming me
for that idea but then we actually had
this young kid who came in as a
shortstop
uh who was a sophomore or something it
was just a little phenom and then i
moved over to
well third base i didn't play well i
played baseball my dad wanted my dad
like really like sports a lot
that's why my name is jocko by the way
um
and i didn't like sports as much as him
at all yeah i like
machine guns right
so but you know i would get put into
sports randomly oh you know go play
little league and i was on the braves
yeah echo gets into this kind of thing
but i just wasn't you know wasn't really
wasn't really my thing so years later i
went and talked to
a professional baseball team and when i
was growing up i remembered the baseball
players
it seemed like most of the baseball
players that were pros
they were like these little guys right
like little dominican guys
little puerto rican guys that were fast
and everything
and when i went and met with this team
which was a few years ago they were
freaking monsters
they were all huge yeah oh they're
massive now i mean it's a whole
different is that a new thing
yeah i mean if you look even if you look
at you know footage from
you know the 80s even early 90s they
were way smaller
how much practice did you play i mean
are you one of the
because sports was different like
nowadays you if you're a kid and you're
gonna play sports your parents are like
cool
you're gonna do that sport you're gonna
play at 365 days a year
you're gonna you're gonna get coaching
you're gonna get some private whatever
uh uh hitting batting coach
that's coming work with you when you're
the kid's like oh we need a batting
coach you're like yeah sure no problem
okay here's my son he's four right was
it like that for you
uh not so much i mean i did do extra
stuff and i did uh
you know did extra work with hitting
coaches and fielding coaches
and uh it was definitely a big part i
mean it was a
i wanted to be a major league baseball
player when i was a kid and
my dad i come from kind of a wrestling
family my dad was a wrestler dude
my brother was alert right and uh
but there he's not a ball sport guy at
all and so he was kind of always blown
away by the idea like how did this
where did this child come from you know
that you know
he used to say that he could he'd throw
a ball at me
like when we were young my brother's
like a year and a half older than me he
could just throw a ball at me when i was
like two
and i would just like reach up and
snatch it freaking
reflexes probably hit off my you know
hit off my brother's chest and land on
the floor but uh
but they had you know they were they
were hard-nosed guys you know my dad's a
was a badass you know what
how old were you started playing
baseball
actually my dad wouldn't let us play he
thought it was too political
when i was uh young just with all the
[__] wait a second i have
no idea what you're talking about how is
baseball political at 19 what is this
or something yes yeah probably i was
born in 74
so yeah you know um it was just a lot of
uh
tension kids oh you mean political like
the
the the dad with the kids the dad and
the emotions of that
you thought like soccer was a better
game a better
family sport that kind of thing so we
played soccer and then he finally
he budged earlier because my brother was
older and we always wanted to play
baseball and then he
i mean it was like minor b's it was like
i was still quite young when i started
playing how good was your brother
at baseball yeah he was fast
bro talk about the freaking hammer of
destruction
ouch i guess the ball was hitting him in
the face when the old man threw into him
he was a wrestler i mean it was a
different oh your brother wrestled my
brother wrestled too yeah
okay yeah he did he wrestled uh my dad
wrestled in college with
oregon state under dale thomas and then
coached some at oregon
as well as oregon state and my brother
uh
he he just wrestled in high school but
he was good in high school yeah
wrestling in california high school is
no joke yeah it was the it's the largest
wrestling tournament
in the world i think he was cif champ i
want to say my brother
he was good props to your brother so at
what point what was your what was you
know
you're dealing with music it was late i
mean it hit me super late i was probably
i said i tell the story and i don't even
know the actual how
what were you listening to when you were
a little kid we were country music fans
my parents were crazy about country and
it was all country
all the time in the in the station wagon
and we would go see country music
concerts um it was kind of the
transition time of country when it was
getting
not over the top cheesy but you know it
was like
alan jackson was coming in and and it
was getting a little more sticky than it
was kind of these heartfelt
songs of my youth but um yeah it was all
it was all country music it was odd for
you know a kid to be um until i really
got to high school
was uh exclusively a country music
listener and and kind of proud of that
fact
um but then i got really into punk when
i was in high school and where'd that
come from
i'm not entirely sure there wasn't
really a kid named
there was a whatever no that was my
check this out one of my buddies who
used to take me to school in the morning
he was more of a and uh
i don't know exactly how i got and so he
would listen to you know listen to
metallica and
danzig and anthrax and uh and then i
started listening to
punk but i was it was more of the
southern california stuff
you know i started kind of getting into
hardcore stuff and then that's
when i got a guitar kind of uh but i was
more like bad religion circle jerks
descendants stuff that was a little more
melodic maybe you know um
and then uh i got a guitar we'd go
drink beers at my buddy's house um and
his dad would play
john prine songs and some of the
quirkier kind of dylan songs
and it was 18 19 maybe and uh
let's go get a guitar when you talk
about music
i don't know if you think this i think
this when i was younger
like within when i met someone shook
their hands hey nice to meet you
within the first let's say seven
to nine minutes of talking to someone i
would say what kind of music do you like
because it would be like a straight up
indicator it would tell you a lot about
them
and nowadays like sometimes i meet who i
got i got four kids and they're all
whatever 20 19 17
and 10. and for a while i would say you
know
what kind of music do you like to these
kids and they're just it's so
there's so much music right there's so
much music out there
that it's you know you know you used to
get the weird avoidance
answer to that question it's like oh i
listen to everything everything yeah you
listen to everything
right i used to say okay so you to me
that used to mean to me
you have no personality if you don't say
bro i like
i like nordic death metal or whatever
then i know we i know you i know who you
are
or you know i like the dead okay i know
who you are or whatever
you know i like uh
whatever hair metal leaf babin
so so it used to identify kind of like
who you are right i mean it was even
part of the fashion like you you
couldn't really like
everything if you were into one thing
that's what you look like
you had the big hair or if you were in a
punk you you know maybe look like a
skinhead if you were in
you know you wore the the pants
if you were in the country you had the
pants with the stitching you know or
it's like yeah dude not it was almost i
identify her yeah and then
people nowadays there's just so much
music and it's so accessible so when i
was a kid in order to get
music that we wanted to hear we had to
go
to new york maybe we had to go to a good
record store which they just weren't all
over the place there's one in waterbury
good brass city get some
um but you know we'd go there and and
but
that was part of the inhibitor the other
part was
money like it cost 21
for an album and you know we just didn't
so i you know i i love music
and i had probably i don't know
30 albums that i just listened to over
and over and over again
you borrow one from someone and of
course we got the little we got tape
cassettes too you get the dub
tape cassette but even that was kind of
hard to get because they would all sound
like crap
not that we really cared that much i
mean let's face it
nowadays everybody kind of listens to
everything
there's a lot out there not to mention
the cro all the crossover see i'm saying
you got country and you got
what the naz kid who's you know old town
road you know they got
we got a lot of crossovers is what i'm
saying so you could
you're just opening it up even wider
even more oh yeah now you really are
listening to everything you see i'm
saying
things are getting crazy crazy too so
it's kind of upsetting though
really like when they start rapping in
in country they do throw you for a loop
sometimes just
like this is not i don't know you're
saying that's upsetting echo doesn't
seem upset by that he doesn't
i'm just observing the landscape of
music at the time at the moment
let me tell you look echo's a decent guy
thank you when we go places he drives i
ride
which means he gets control of the music
situation yes
which is a problem for you i can see how
that could be yes
so uh so did you get so you said you
played d1 college so you get into
college
do you get into college where did you go
to college i went
two years at a junior college in
huntington beach
golden west college and then i did two
years at st mary's college
which was in the east bay in moraga
same league as at the time at least was
uh like pepperdine santa clara
loyola uh san diego
wait uc san diego okay um that league
and then did you so is that when you
were talking that you got a guitar was
that still in high school you got to go
it was prior to that so probably when i
was 19. probably about when
i don't know if it was the summer
between my senior year in high school
oh and college your dad held you back
you were old right
wrestling like families their kids are
going to school they're like starting
they're they're graduating when they're
23 years old
but he was a college professor so i
think education was it was equally
if not more important to him than than
you know dominance in sports or
wrestling so
dude wrestling's crazy man right i mean
i know i mean my kids wrestle and it's
like it's mayhem
it's mayhem you want to talk about
political your dad's talking about
soccer
come to a freaking wrestling tournament
it's insane man
it's insane go to the state
championships in bakersfield california
it's insane it's awesome okay so you're
so you're still in high school
and you're 27 years old
no so you're still in high school and
that's when you go you hear
you hear a little bit of uh acoustic
music that you go oh
yeah just that my friends my friend's
dad would play we'd just drink beers and
he would hang out and he would play
just songs and i was like oh that looks
easy oh wait oh so he was playing guitar
he was playing guitar and singing
himself he wasn't playing records he
wasn't spinning record he was actually
singing
and playing them sambulo damn and uh
yeah he wrote down a few chords for me
and then i was on my way
i kinda didn't i didn't even really
learn
songs i started writing songs almost
immediately would not and not with you
with the agenda to be like i'm going to
be a
musician a songwriter i was still a
baseball player that was still the dream
you know
and uh i don't know i just kept writing
were you feeling any any of the burn the
baseball burnout at that point yeah
totally i
had it i had it no and i that you had
fourth grade
now the reality of it is in high school
i was still super serious about it once
i hit junior college
i was less serious about it and didn't
even wasn't even that great i don't
think and that
actually uh what what happened to cal
ripken over here bro
you know you started i don't know you
started smoking weed deserving during
the summer you know
i mean at that level at division one
everyone goes to
alaska or somewhere some far off place
playing
summer ball all the time and i never did
that ever
i would just surf and hang out at 20th
street with my buddies
and then you know they come and i come
back from summer and they're like
you went to shape you know like but uh
yeah it wasn't
i had kind of lost the love for it a
little bit but then we're gonna pay for
my college education and
they saw me at some all-star game then
and i went off you know i hit like a
home run and two doubles or something
like that and saw that i was it
could move move well for a big person
and uh
i got a scholarship out of that and so i
was like well okay a couple more years
it's not going to hurt anybody you know
it's actually really fun
so so then you you so when you got your
guitar you're still in high school and
you're immediately writing songs
like you had that you had that thought
that
i i kind of for my my interpretation of
that thought is
it's a pain to try and learn what
someone else is doing but if i just make
something up then it's a little easier
was there any of that there
it may have been that's like the story
of my whole existence it's kind of just
the easiest path to something and i'd be
like oh
well you didn't even really try that
hard to be doing that you know
and i'm assuming you never took any
lessons or anything no i never did
i never took any lessons i mean the
first song i wrote i wrote a song when i
knew and i knew
uh like e minor and and g
and then wrote a song like about suicide
or something like something super
but like a narrative about like some guy
jumping off a building or something and
i was like why is it and i wasn't even
that disturbed as a child
you know i was like pretty i was pretty
happy-go-lucky
but um yeah this and he immediately
started writing
what was the name of the first song it's
called the jumper damn
has it ever been released no and i can't
i was trying to remember the
the lyrics and it's i mean they're not
they weren't as
nearly as crafted as they are today you
know
well you got me beat because i think the
first song that my band
we had a bunch of bands when i was a kid
and uh the
the name that we've kind that's kind of
has survived is bronson's children
named after charles bronson and even
though we never made an album and even
though
we did record uh about 15 songs in the
studio
but more important than that we made
cool t-shirts so we've had these cool
t-shirts that
we have them on this we have them on the
jocko store they're they're just a
picture of
charles bronson's face and then
underneath in little kids
like uh toddler writing it says
bronson's children you know with like a
backwards r
type thing but i think the first
song that i can remember was there was
this weird
televangelist dude that was on late
night tv his name was dr gene
scott and i remember
yes yes that's him yeah that's him
the public access yeah public access and
he was kind of
he was kind of like one of these people
he sort of berated the audience kind of
right
right i think he was like the gateway
between like donahue or maury povich or
whatever or whatever that
i don't even know but anyways we would
watch
you kind of berate his you know you need
to donate now it was one of those things
and there's then there's the whatever
and so the first uh song
in bronson's children was a song called
dr scott get off the air
yes and there was a great little chorus
where
where it was get off the air and then
someone was in the back going get him
off the air
and get off the air there it was so yeah
so you were beating me man you were
already going deep
early i went like it went dark super
early yeah
and then so so at some point during
college so did you play your whole four
years of baseball yeah
graduated in four years and played all
four years and then what would you what
did you major in
or whatever history history was my major
were you thinking you were
did that was that any was that just an
easiest thing to take
earlier i had an inspiring teacher in
junior college that made history
interesting and so decided to go that
path i don't really retain much
of it um but i some of the time they
seep into songs and whatnot there'll be
kind of period
piece songs that i'll write
but yeah not with the idea that i was
going to be
a teacher i mean what do you really do
with it right i mean i'm i'm asking you
that yeah
no i was still like oh i don't know what
i'm going to do you know now i got this
guitar thing oh maybe
maybe i'll do that now you know how long
did it take you to start thinking oh man
i can maybe i could maybe make something
work it took me a long time
to even consider myself a musician i
probably had
i don't know 30 songs under my belt and
would play it
you know i would play at the pub on
campus
how much practice did you do
not like what you got the guitar did you
okay that's awesome no i mean it's still
well no it's still it's still a
primitive i still have a very primitive
style of playing and there's nothing
i don't really dazzle anybody with uh
with my virtuosity you know it's just
like it's the vehicle for
the songs and for the voice and and uh
you know i know i do have my own style
kind of of playing because it's fairly
percussive but
it's primitive mm-hmm you know i mean i
probably break strings more than
anyone maybe ever
an acoustic guitar for sure you pick up
the guitar and you you start writing
songs you start playing
songs but you didn't you're not one of
these people that like i've known i had
friends growing up where they got
obsessed and it was they were just like
learning scales and whatever the hell
else you learned when you're trying to
get good guitar which i
yeah i never did i never never took
lessons or never
[Music]
yeah and i i don't it still it took me a
while to go like oh this is maybe what i
want to do even
and i just kept on writing songs and i
started having kind of a catalogue of
songs
so so when you graduate from college
do are you what did you do did you get a
job
i waited tables i went back i lived with
my
parents for a while uh to save up some
money waited tables and then moved to
san francisco
and waited tables and then with kind of
the intention that i was going to go and
start hitting the clubs and trying to
make some kind of a
a presence of my songwriting or my
performance or whatever it was going to
be you know and uh
what did san francisco seem like the
move for some reason
i i don't know if because it was close
in proximity to where i went
to college i'm not sure why we chose
that i think my brother had a job
there um that was lined up and so we
went there
and lived together and my brother lived
together and uh
but it was shitty it was not a good
environment it was when
dj started taking over almost all small
clubs what year is this
this is 98 to maybe
i lived in san francisco probably play
once a year twice a year in the corner
of some
[__] dive bar or like at a coffee shop
you know
smuggle some tequila and ruin the show
on the second sec
kind of thing but i yeah so 98 to 2002
you're up there
you're you're playing occasionally in
the back of some freaking whatever
yeah you know and and waiting tables to
to survive
and uh where you were were you
but this was your goal your goal was be
a musician at this point
yeah but it was loose and lazy kind of
and just not
not realized i mean i used to not get
gigs i didn't have i didn't have [__] i
didn't have uh
so i would make cassette tapes on my
brothers through my brother's pioneer
uh dual cassette player right
through the pa through the pa and i
would record and i would lay down 10
songs and then i would send them to
friends
and send them to family for a presents
for like christmas or
or for whatever right and and
i had no press
i'm picturing people opening up i'm like
oh we got another
freaking tape oh yeah
thank you this thing's going in the [__]
can
oh that's painful so you so you're
thinking are you thinking that's gonna
be a hobby you just think hey it's fun
i i want to do it but i'm not i don't
have the know-how
or maybe the drive really to really know
what i'm doing i mean my brother was my
manager i saw this he was doing [__] but
we found this old tape and it had uh
we had this little band in um in uh in
huntington beach like right when i would
have been playing guitar for like
six months maybe and these guys heard me
singing they're like holy [__] like
let's start a band and they one guy
played bass and then i played drums and
we started a band called living room
right
this is
started in the living room as well you
know so there was all this it was
silly and we're [__] terrible and uh
but on the cassette it says living room
and then
boom no there's no title to the whatever
the the
little ep thing it's only cassettes by
the way and
matt smith my brother's name and his his
his phone number
big multiple times so it was like
it looks pretty bro i was freaking
hollywood people just looking for that
number to dial right they're like wow
this guy must have a bunch of clients
probably
so i'm still trying to figure this out
right you're in san francisco it seems
like you are
very persistent but not very focused or
maybe something like that or is it just
you just didn't know what to do
i i was i was passionate about writing
songs and i
would keep writing songs so these uh
laughable
cassettes that i was creating were
making their way down so i actually had
a buddy who's in the surf industry
and uh he was a rep for for uh some surf
companies and
these cassette tapes started going to
other people he would give one to one
and then they would make google
consecutive
to cassette you know old school viral
right old school
viral jack smith as as much as it could
be and that but wait a second i'm just
going to confirm this
we're in 1998 or 2000 this is before
that oh this is before that when i was
making the cassettes and getting them
out so this was the
this was one my couple junior college
years i think that i was creating these
cassettes and they were kind of
go moving around but i was unaware that
other people were listening to them or
other people were making duplicates of
this
and then i got a call from one of the
guys shelter the guy who made shelter
christmas christmas
yeah when i was living in san francisco
and he said hey i want to use one of
your songs and
one of my surf films and i was like what
like how do you know
you didn't know him at the time i didn't
know him no oh this was one of the
and this was one of just the cassette
one to this guy to this guy this guy and
then he ended up with one and one of the
songs he said he wanted to use
off this one of these cassettes and i
was like why
you know because i was used to you know
surf films were
airs and and punk and fast ass music and
they're like he's like you know we were
making this kind of more arty thing it
was just me
and an acoustic guitar it was wrong yeah
i was wrong
it was a song um
and then that yeah because that was that
was like it was like a soul
kind of yeah
the malloy brothers are all cool guys
totally
um then so so that happens
and then all of a sudden does that give
you a little
that desperado like did that happen that
didn't even that didn't give me the
um that gave me a little validation and
said like oh yeah maybe i'm
doing the right or doing something this
is maybe something to pursue harder
they asked me to come and play the um
all these are just you and your
guitar oh yeah there's no band no band
just me solo and that's
par partially of how why i play guitar
the way i do because i used to just fill
the space
with everything not with noodling but
just with strumming and
there's a lot of up down and uh
percussive stuff
um and then they asked me to play the uh
the premiere of the movie down in san
diego so i come down and i play whatever
30 minutes before
the movie and i see people singing along
to other songs of mine from these
silly cassettes right and i'm like what
is going on
what is this and i don't have [__] going
on in san francisco my brother had gone
off and was like
uh working at the olympics or something
so he had left san francisco and i had
this like drunk ass roommate
and i packed my [__] up and quit my job
and then moved down to southern
california and then started kind of
fresh
a little more focused but not very
focused still
you know and then that's it was a long
road
you know a lot of couches then it was
just couches then i didn't have another
job
so wait so then you you said i missed it
you moved to san diego or you moved to
l.a
i moved to orange county to orange
county yeah they'll surf industry in
there
yeah was that kind of like a dream i
mean for the
uh the variety of songs i write which
many of them are quite dark or at least
emotional or visceral in a way
that the surf industry i thought was an
odd kind of place to
to pick it up and pick up you know
go like oh yeah this is you know this
might make you cry let's put that in the
in a surf film you know it was it was an
odd place to start i thought or at least
to get
what year was it that you moved down
here 2002
oh okay what year did shelter come out
um probably around then okay i bet
it's that same time it was pretty
immediate after after
that happened i was like oh [__] i
didn't just nothing was happening and
i'd been in san francisco for four years
nothing was going to happen in san
francisco
you know i wasn't i was idle i was too
idle and i needed something to push
myself
um and so i needed to make a change
so you get down here then what's the
next step now you're not now you're not
waiting tables anymore
are you somehow getting by and hardly
though i mean
like uh playing every other wednesday at
the sushi bar in seal beach and playing
in the corner this
barbecue restaurant in in santa ana and
just like
take jar out tip jar making you know
between 50 and 300 bucks a pop and
sleeping on people's couches
stayed at my buddy's house for like
maybe a year and a half in their guest
room
no that's a buddy super i mean he's a
beautiful man
scott marsh uh yeah i know i'm grateful
for that time because it really allowed
me to
i don't know i i it allowed me to at
least craft
what i was doing and at least get some
um stage time performance time
um before anything was really happening
so how long were you in that situation
before when's the first time you went
into a studio and
recorded um not on a pioneer tape deck
yeah it was after so as after shelter
came out
um those
same cassettes had gotten to the guy bob
hurley
who owns hurley and
he paid for me to make my first album
and i actually made it with this a
surfer up in or in san diego
peter king do you know peter i don't
know um
he had a home studio at his house and i
made my first album which was hogtied
like a
rodeo which i discontinued
and redid at some point in my career
because i wasn't totally
loving how it turned out because i was
super green and never been in studio
i only knew the pioneer you know i
didn't know that it was more than a
record button right
echo charles take note right yeah yeah
play and record at the same time at the
same time okay there was some
complications
you know what what happened to that
album like
what happened that album that you felt
like you lost control of it a little bit
did they go and over produce it or
something are they like hey we're gonna
bring in
jim you know jimmy on the freaking lead
guitar and get his fender in here and
start
cranking out yeah i mean i was raw and i
i liked kind of some of the rawness and
it seemed to get a little too
produced um in a way i would just like
leave
uh leave town i would go somewhere and
visit some people and then they would
have musicians would come in and play on
it and then they'd be like hey check
this out and i'll be like oh i don't
know
you know it was it wasn't i wasn't at
the command at all
that's weird it was out of my hands
which is normally which is that was the
only time i really made that
mistake you know um but you live in your
learn and in happenstance to look back
and go like
you know you discontinue and then you
re-recorded it later which seems like
it was a moment in time and even if i
was green i think the songs were still
good
um why i re-recorded it and discontinued
that other one i don't know why
but you can fight you try to find that
one like there's some like japanese
sites and stuff that'll have that cd
which there weren't that many of them
because they were just like uh
that are like 500 bucks or something
just stupid
you know for this well and you could
probably get it on the
internet just like these webs so that's
so that's the first album that comes out
does it come out is that the right word
did it even come out or was it just like
hey we're making it work
it doesn't come out i sell it it shows
that's it
you know we have this kind of fictitious
label that bob
and this guy paul gomez make and it is
uh
yeah nothing really happens i'm still
playing at the sushi bar
um doing that for and i was in that
state for quite some time you know
like two years two years of sushi bar
jar sushi bar tip jar
then what what what happened from there
that got you away from the sushi bar in
the tip jar
uh it was um
i met i think i moved up because i met
my
my wife and i moved up to
um los angeles and met some people
got kind of a manager um
and we went in the studio and recorded
my first ep
is this this is just the buffalo and
it's
yeah it's i think it's five six songs on
that
um which was super stripped down now
was this um who who's who's paying for
this you know who is running who bought
you studio time
this was a my manager at the time
was managing uh donovan frankenwriter oh
okay
and i so he i would open up for him i
started opening up for him and i would
get some exposure doing that
and met the keyboard player this guy who
actually played for the eels as well
okay um rusty oh i forgot his last name
he went by cool g
murder and he was kind of he had rusty
whatever but he had this like
his redhead had this big like ginger
beard kind of like
wispy you know
not a whole lot of hair and uh call
himself culture he was cool
she was cool what was his nickname cool
g murderer cool g murder it says if you
look
if you had that ep and you looked on
produced by it says produced by cool g
murder oh
i will check that out
uh so so that so you record this thing
are we still pre like internet um
whatever
mp3 situations yeah yeah we're still
sales are still yeah i don't even know
for digital
yeah i don't know are we i don't know if
it was itunes and that stuff it
had been i don't know either i don't
think so because i think they date
that ep on itunes is something way later
than it
actually was you know so so when that
album comes out
is it what happens is it freaking wasn't
just no factor
i independently release it myself and
it's just me selling it basically at
uh shows and i think when the digital
format comes up i get it up on there and
i'm
that's it nothing is happening i ended
up doing that for a couple
so you're in that state still and it's
still a couple albums and then i'd put a
couple more albums out doing that
in that state almost and what at what
point did you
start to feel some forward moment like
like i was saying earlier man i went and
saw you at ucsd in like a little cafe
and there's 15 people in there
and i was actually like me my wife her
friends
our friends we're all sitting there yeah
and everybody's i remember that and
everyone's like
sitting indian style on the ground yeah
yeah and i'm super stoked
i'm like this is so rad you know like
yeah
i mean it's been just this super long
haul
of not too many spikes i mean
later i'm starting later i mean it's not
until i get
um you know probably start start getting
the actual tv licenses where stuff
starts getting more serious
and that doesn't come until what year
i was still independent didn't have uh
i had hogtied revisited now
under my belt which is a full-length
album and two eps
and i didn't have a manager i didn't
have a booking agent anything and my
lawyer
asked the music supervisor for sons of
anarchy to
to lunch and said hey i got this guy
it'll work
he writes murder songs and conflicted
emotional songs
you know that that and um
when you're in that state so you're in
this state like there's got to be a
point there's got to be a thought that
goes through your mind
of all right you know like this ain't
gonna work i gotta
i gotta figure out how i gotta feed my
family i got to figure out how i'm going
to get a mortgage i got to figure out
how i'm going to buy a house
was that fought in your mind or was it a
good were you getting by enough were you
having i mean you you obviously you love
playing live at least as far as i can
tell you freaking love
playing live is that a good enough time
we're like hey this is a cool job right
now and i'm good with it yeah i mean
it was very small means and and
i we didn't need that money much money
to survive really at that point
um oh yeah i remember i got
off uh another surf movie
i did uh this one from jason baffa
called single thin yellow and i
did a uh
a little piece off that and that was the
first time i ever like wrote to picture
one of the only times actually
and i came up with that song and that
idea and then i i
i redid it and recorded it on
my first ep um and create made it into a
more of a song
one before was just this thing they used
that person
that that piece like walmart called me
for commercial
out of nowhere too i didn't have a
publisher they thought i was a publisher
and quoted me some money there he gave
me i was like holy [__]
and i was like walmart i was like no
[__] yeah
and then and then i want that walmart
money son
but then i remember i was like oh wait
let me you know i don't want to shoot
myself in the foot let me pass it on to
my manager at the time right
who's pretty green he ends up getting
less money somehow than i had negotiated
initially that's because that's but
still but it was more it was
it was more money than i'd ever seen and
it was like oh okay here's
you know i could have lived off that
that was more money than i'd made
probably in the previous four years wow
you know of doing
of doing the music so you are getting
it's like it's like you're uh
you know when you were a kid and you had
some girlfriend and
and like she would break up with you but
she would string you along
right you know that and people say don't
string don't string people along
it's like you were getting strung along
by yeah the little carrots
i mean there's a carrot you know another
good made some good tips tonight
then you get the big call from walmart
it's on like donkey kong
right so then so that was from single
thing
yellow which is a kick-ass movie they
take this board
and they send it around the world a
bunch of different people surfing a
bunch of different wild spots
um but this is
still still you're not you know
able to just or are you able to just
survive on
on being a musician at this point yeah
and i was i had been for
for a bit i did uh use my college degree
for a little substitute teaching which
was hilarious
oh man hilarious become heartbreaking at
the same time why do you say that
uh just you know uh
middle school kids are pretty dangerous
you know i'm pretty confused and pissed
and so i end up
breaking up more fights than i was
teaching anybody anything or you know i
mean i wasn't
there's not much of a a lesson plan
often left for the substitute teacher so
you're showing a movie or you're just
trying to keep the kids safe
i'm gonna say don't get don't get thrown
out the window it's the lesson plan
right so uh but i didn't do that that
that long or very
very um very often um
when you when you're in these when
you're in this period of your life
i mean the the songs that you write the
music that you write the lyrics that you
write
i'm i'm projecting my thoughts onto this
but
you know when you're sitting working in
a dive bar somewhere playing a gig
and you look over in the corner and you
see this character
is does that develop into hey you know i
know what that guy's thinking or
i'm thinking about what that person's
life is like does that add is it good
that you went through this time period
of
of where you were kind of struggling
through and making things happen
did you does that incorporate into your
the things you think about
i mean i honestly think the way that i
did it
um was beneficial to me as a songwriter
as an artist for this long of a time
that if i would have had somebody come
in and go like hey wow this guy's
he can sing and he writes these pretty
good songs but like we can why don't we
develop this guy into something else
into a country store or something else
and instead i was able to be 100
true to the songs i write the artists
that i wanted to be
and never had to do anything that i
didn't want to do
it always my vision and always 100 from
me which is
super rare these days especially i mean
there's like you know
a song on the radio you got 15 people
wrote it you know
it's like it's it's kind of unheard of
and but
i think that this super long haul that
it's taken me and even now i'm still a
little secret you know it's not like i'm
a superstar or people know who i am i
walk down the street
it's like rare for me to get noticed you
know i'm always kind of like
put off by somebody going like hey are
you are you
are you the i was like oh yeah i am and
then i'll be like oh [__] you know i
love you people that really like me
really like me
but most people don't know about me you
know which i'm kind of
like it's a sweet spot kind of for me i
mean i'm not making millions of dollars
but i'm doing okay
i can survive and provide um
but i'm not uh
you know i don't i can still be be me do
what i want to do and and not
not be uh you know afraid to go out in
public at all
that that's good just uh so
so you were just getting to the point
where i cut you off and
redirected the story in a totally
different direction because that was
really cool that's fine
but uh you were talking about the
your so you got this manager guy
and he knows
um the musician director from
sons of anarchy that was actually post
so i had my first guy and i
uh first manager one he's actually my
second manager
who was managing donald and frank writer
and i ended up touring with him for
probably a year and a half when i was
with him
um it went to japan went all over the
world and this was when he was
he peaked when donovan was kind of
peaking and
were you just living the dream it was i
mean they let me travel on the bus
i was like you know we weren't on the
sushi bar anymore you know don't feel
good
bro and just to see the world where
you're seeing the world and you're
getting perspectives and different
you know it really opens your mind
traveling when i was in the seal teams i
was on deploy when i would be on
deployment
i would know in my mind like every day i
would know that
this was like the best you know i was
kind of just
loving life you know living you know
people always say living the dream
i was living the dream i was actually
doing exactly what i always dreamed of
doing for my whole life
that's amazing it seems like that's what
would be
you know you being on tour it was i just
had low
i didn't have and maybe that's my been
my outlook
a lot of the time to kind of have low
expectations and then not be really that
disappointed
and even when i'm not getting accolades
or i'm not getting
you know playing huge rooms or or but
making enough money to be
okay and feel pretty okay about what i'm
doing and still being true to myself
um was enough and it's always kind of
been enough for me
okay so you get a pretty good launch you
get a taste of the road
right get a taste of the road bro
you're there and and then did that when
you get done
touring with that tour what's the next
step
um you know we started i
don't know where we're at where was i at
that moment i'm probably
the the next big step is getting the
sons of anarchy stuff for sure
that that that put me in a place
um where now i could go well after the
show
really like it was like the third season
i think they started using my stuff
and how and so it's uh you i cut once
again i just cut you off randomly and
said hey let's take a so how did that
come about that that you ended up on
sons of anarchy uh no so is my lawyer
steve sessa
who i still have today uh invited the
music supervisor to lunch
and said listen i have this guy he's an
unsight artist doesn't have any
management doesn't have anything
um puts on his own albums i think he was
a big fan of the show
of santa monica and he's like you know
the conflict and these
you know it's like the show is basically
these
uh emotional men doing kind of terrible
[__]
you know and i have a lot of that kind
of conflict in some of my songs too that
it's something that
this guy feels like kind of a badass but
god he's maybe kind of a sweetheart
underneath or you feel for this guy
who's really it's a murder song
you know but you're he's kind of the
hero though at the same time
so it's this conflict to him
was perfect for that show and then
he he gave him gave him my whole catalog
basically and then
in not that long at all they they're
like okay we're gonna use this in the
next
and you know in three episodes or
something and uh
but that was a slow thing as well you
know that was they'd use us one song and
then they used another song but then
they ended up using
i think seven or eight of my own songs
that i
that were my own compositions that were
already out there um
and then they had me come and sing on
stuff so stuff that they would create
that was part of the soundtrack
and just how they used music in that
show i don't know if you watched it but
it was very
we do these montages at the end that
would be
the song would be part of the of the
story and it would just be these
montages visuals
and they would play the song at full
length at full volume
and it would be like another character
and then i think people started
recognizing my voice
and saying man what is this maybe we
should go deeper you know into this
and at that point we had i hadn't been
to europe on my own
as an artist i'd only opened up for
people and you don't really know what
kind of
uh legs you have in places you don't
know when you don't have any history in
places and if you just opened up for
somebody you don't really have history
because really you're just playing for
their people
so then shit's going better and getting
better and we go
man we gotta go we gotta check out
europe i don't know what's you know
starting to play bigger rooms all over
the country
and nobody
no no clubs who want us they never heard
of us you know and they're like and then
we're like well at least we'll
you know we got a festival somewhere so
we're like okay we're gonna play this
festival in spain or something so
but we gotta try to play in london and
just see what tickets are like see what
happens
so we play this like little tiny room
we're gonna play like a 200 cap room
that sells out like an hour
they're like oh [__] well they're like
what's going on and then they like well
let's bump up the room
and then they bump it up to like 700
capacity which was bigger than i'm
playing most of the places in the states
and then that sells out another hour and
then they're like wow what's going on
and then that
so we just went and we played a couple
shows in europe and then realized like
okay this is a viable
market like we can make some money over
here and we have a fan base
and i think almost due to the popularity
of that show
um you know at that point i signed with
the label
you know small kind of boutique label
which basically was
these two guys that that were producers
and engineers who
produced and engineered uh four albums
um i just just have left now and i'm
only with the difference
what made you decide to go why did you
need you've been doing it yourself what
made you make the transition
it was not um
i didn't i never had any even though
there wasn't a much of a machine
behind those other albums and still now
not really
um i just wanted to get in the game you
know what i mean i'd never been in the
game
you know and i was just like i'm just an
island i'm still kind of an island but
then
i was like i wasn't even in the game you
know and they're like you know i think
somebody was just like dude getting the
game
like what are you doing like you know
the labels you know you know it wasn't
like i had uh
the know-how or any of the anything when
i'm independently releasing things no
it wasn't like it was [__] six months
set up to be like oh
all right the album's gonna come out may
you know 20th and we're gonna be
promoting this thing for now
it was when it was done what's my
marketing plan look like for the next
album there was nothing i it would just
go up it would
just put it up it would be i finished
something and then i would just put it
up
you know digitally and and make cds
so so then you sign you sign with these
guys is that the right terminology yeah
yeah and we did like a three album four
album
deal with them um
are you the um is this
all your decision making you're the guy
uh
yeah i ended up getting my manager
right when i was signing i was looking
for somebody else i was like in between
i
think i had like three different
managers who were all
i don't want to say hacks but like they
weren't um
they just did probably but they they
weren't as they did
they weren't as professional or as right
for me
i'll just say that they weren't they
weren't maybe right for me to try to get
me to the another plateau
and now i got jeff farner who's great
and and
smart and political and um
also though very in my corners for still
allowing me to
have my vision and and do what i want to
do musically um
so right right before that uh we do the
deal
i sign with him as well or i bring him
on as my manager
been with him ever since and then you
that so now you're officially in the
game now you're selling out places in
europe
and what does it look like when you get
back to the states because it's weird
you know it's weird how that can happen
and i got some other friends and that
are musicians and like
overseas they're freaking massive and
back here there's just not
not action i mean it's it's crazy and i
don't even know
some markets i mean we've never been to
south america like if you look on my
comments you look on any youtube
thing i have every other comment has
come to brazil
or something brazil but we've never been
to brazil it's far
uh it's a little sketchy right i don't
know uh
when we'll get there i want to get there
um you know but
uh we're doing better it's a slow build
and we never go down you know which i
appreciate but
still in places like the south we
haven't had that much touring history
i've probably done like two or three
tours there
and we're still building that um
is it weird because how do you
categorize your music
that's part because that's got to be an
issue that's part of the issue and that
that's an issue
with labels some of the time too because
they don't understand it it doesn't fit
in any really category
you know even you have this americana
idea now
it doesn't it's not air quotes
[Music]
it just it doesn't seem i don't know
it it feels like uh i don't belong in
that genre either i mean part of it does
part of it's kind of this country
there's country elements there's rock
elements there's
some more aggressive more punk stuff
there's um
folk stuff there's ballads there's you
know it's it
it belongs in anything it's organic yeah
and it comes from
mostly it comes from three guys playing
or you know if we put some other stuff
on albums but it's
it's uh we're the most stripped down
band
that that um you'll ever see really i
mean other than if it's one guy playing
guitar
i mean it's three guys with no effects
yeah there's no vocal effects there's no
effects on my guitar there's no
there's no nothing it's three guys so
that so that's an issue
because you can't say oh there's this
you know this other band that kind of
fits in the white buffalo category and
there we can play with these four other
bands we can do a festival or whatever
because where do you really fit
at the same time though but you can fit
in all other little categories too
there's benefits to that too because i
can play a rock festival
yeah i can play a country festival you
know
yeah cause you're kind of like your own
you know your own little your own little
genre yeah i never
hopefully that i have my own sound kind
of yeah you know which is okay and not
to mention i think you're the only
person that writes murder songs
right or at least the ones you could
dance and love songs and murder songs oh
i guess that's right i guess i'm leaving
out all my deaf metal brothers out there
who are
write 100 murder songs you're the only
one out there doing acoustic
folk murder songs even though have you
ever heard
what is it called viking folk medal have
you ever heard that
viking folk medal yes yes no they play
like
traditional viking instruments but
they're playing
metal really yes i mean that's
another group you could come from like
viking blood so that might be uh
maybe that's my genre well at least you
can slide in there you can maybe do some
some viking uh folk metal what are they
called festivals
i mean if they exist absolutely probably
somewhere in scandinavia right i'm sure
there's that
going on so when you when you um
when you're do do the where do the songs
come from
like the majority of them if not all of
them come from
just silence from nowhere you know a lot
of them will be
gibberish or something they just come in
out of out of being quiet
and they often
i will say something sing something and
i will recognize what the important part
is or the piece of it that that has some
validity or worth
and expand on that one little idea
most of the time sometime i'll sing
something that just i don't even know
where it came from you know
it's i can sing a whole verse in a
course not not with not with an idea
that
i'm going to write a song about this i
don't even know what they're about
initially
and then i craft them into things that
hopefully have some kind of emotional
response so there's some level
of you being on the lookout for a little
nugget of goodness that you can grab
onto and plant and
i just feel lucky like that i feel like
they're lucky little diamonds that come
out of
[__] the ether you know what i mean
and
i i think my gift is recognizing what
those little lucky moments are
to go like oh let me grab that that's a
good idea you know and i do i
i know that i can craft something off of
one very small idea
to realize how i can turn that into a
whole concept or a whole song
pretty quick um
but yeah i don't know i wish i had
better stories about it
i was talking to robert o'keene who did
a podcast with him and he was like
tell me what where were we at what was
this you know what's the inspiration
behind this i'm like
this is no there's no inspiration it's
just imagined
you know it's like imagination is that
the inspiration
yeah but it's not in my head i'm not
like it's not there's no um
pre-thought about it rarely it's born in
your head
yeah it just comes from your head yeah
that's like the
so i was an english major in college
i'll have you know so what you're saying
right now what you're saying right now
i'm gonna put you
on the spot so what you're saying right
now is there was these people and there
was all there's all this controversy and
i'm not even remember it that well
because i really don't remember that
much of college
but there would be people that would say
you know i wrote this poem
just it just i just wrote it and i'm
talking like classical like
real famous literature people oh the
word is that this person just wrote this
it just came out and it's like they
didn't have to work for it
that's kind of what you're doing you're
just like hey i'm rarely i'm over here
just
freaking just developing nuggets of gold
i'm rarely doing that they're rarely
that easy but the inception of them the
beginnings
of them are that easy but some of the
time it's a very small little
piece of something and it's not very
rarely sometimes
i have sat down in my in my lifetime and
and just something spilled out
and then you're like holy [__] there it
is like love song number one is one kind
of like that that
was it off my first ep that just kind of
spilled out and then i was like well
there's
like what was that what is that about
you know there's even a moment in the
song where i'm still like what is that
even about you know
and um and just left it in kind of you
know now i i edit more stuff
now you know and make every word perfect
or try as perfect as i feel like i can
make it you know
but um
and then what's the deal on you know
what do you owe
in other words are you like hey i better
get another album out in another
you know because you just you just put
out your latest album what
a few few months ago yeah april april
17th
april 17th so now do you start feeling
the pressure
in your head of i need to do more
because i needed to cut another album do
you start feeling pressure in your head
that you got ideas in there that need to
get out
do you not even think about it i don't
even think about it i i don't like i
i um i'll write here and there and
there'll be little snippets in my phone
but i don't really think about it
even this last record
who i did with shooter jennings produced
it um
that i didn't have i didn't think i had
hardly any songs
going into talking with him and meeting
with him
and the night before we went out
drinking like the first time and didn't
even talk about working together really
we're just talking about life and
and just get drunk we got drunk like
where did you meet him
uh where where where did we get drunk at
or where did you know where did you get
drunk
uh frolic room on like hollywood
well i mean randomly no no no it was set
up it was like a
blind date between our managers set us
up thinking that this might be a
match made in heaven but uh no i went so
i went in the first time to meet him to
kind of show him
what i'd been working on or if something
you know to develop some songs and i was
like i don't have [__]
i feel like [__] i woke up the night
before
and uh had an idea
sang it into my phone and was like okay
well at least i
can show them that tomorrow and we'll
work on that all day
and see what happens well i take that to
him and i sing it to him
i think him kind of the idea it was
actually quite realized but it's like
my son was like sleeping i had this
little tiny studio [__] place for
sleep sleeping and my son's sleeping on
the
so you're like oh sorry like i couldn't
even make out
what i'm saying but i'm trying to be
quiet just to not wake him
and i show him this thing the next day
and then i sing it and we
work it out in like 20 minutes and then
i already have it kind of realized and
it's like
what else do you have i was like oh i
have oh this and he's like well that's
amazing
explore that i mean what else you have
and i was like oh how about this and
he's like that's
yeah do that like explore that and i
would just and then we just went down
and i was like okay and then after that
little meeting
i went on just a like a i go on little
riding
tears little benders and then i just
basically wrote the whole album in about
a week a week and a half and before i
was like
you know i have little snippets that are
coming in you know
but then to realize and then finish them
really fast
sometimes and sometimes you know it's
like added
sometimes it's out of just inspiration
and desperation
so the little pressure can maybe squeeze
something out of you have you ever been
to a point where you were feeling
pressure but just nothing was coming out
i had another album uh
loving the death of damnation that i
remember i used to with the old
producers i would go and i would sing i
would give have all these ideas and i
would come in and they would be like
okay yeah let's explore that one let's
let's do that
work on that one and a lot of time it
would be like every one but i'd have
like 20
ideas 25 ideas or something like that
right and for that album i had like
you know it was about time to record and
i had maybe six ideas
that i played in and they're all kind of
like on all of them you know
and then i was like [__] it let's just
start wednesday i'm like what are we
gonna do wednesday and i was like
i'll be ready wednesday yeah you pretty
wednesday
and then we just did that one like that
but that was completely out of
desperation
and then hit a lucky uh prolific
time little little lucky streak yeah
great album how did you link up with uh
with matt and um christopher
so matt has been drumming
who's a freaking animal by the way he's
a freaking
animal i mean as far as i don't think i
would be the performer
i am today without matt no you guys you
guys get you guys look at each other and
you guys just get go off
it's freaking savage it's awesome i mean
especially for like an acoustic trio
who'd you think
wouldn't be terribly aggressive you know
and he's just sticks are flying and
breaking
and shards of wood or you know getting
pulled out of dudes women and children
at some point i realized that you called
him the machine right
yeah and then i would every show i'd go
to and i'd be like machine i would get
all crazy
but and then like the last couple times
i've gone other people were yelling and
i was kind of
disappointed i kind of felt like oh that
well whenever you started it
i don't know man it was just kind of
just gone yeah cause he just goes nuts
so
so i'm sorry how did you link up with
him um that was actually the first album
i did for the hurley guy hogtied
uh like a rodeo i've had matt since then
no way
he wasn't on that album but there was a
guy tommy andrews who's from san diego
as well who was my bass player for the
first 10 years of my career
uh played guitar on that album and
knew matt and this guy russell hayden
who played banjo and dobro like the most
evil
[__] banjo ever you heard and uh but
it was perfect
for us creepy evil banjo bring it and
he'd like where he wouldn't
he would like dress like liza minnelli
and like to know any eyebrows and he'd
be like
like [__] awesome banjo player um
but anyways uh but i met matt through
this guy tommy andrews and we all did it
it was the first time i ever felt
before that i only played by myself yeah
really never played never performed even
when i'm in the corner of any place was
always by myself and that was the first
time i was like whoa
this is what it feels like to really
feel and feed off of
other people's energy and playing and
matt's played with me ever since and
christopher's been with us for maybe
matt and christopher are like best
buddies and
hoffy's not even a wasn't even a bass
player
he's a producer and engineer so he can
play everything right he's one of those
guys
yeah but now he's a really good bass
player now yeah um
what's when look
i i try and explain this to people you
gotta get the albums for sure
and then you gotta go see you gotta go
see the live shows it's freaking insane
i i think yeah i mean i i don't know i
mean we just go [__] go ape [__] i
mean we don't know
and i just think it's very visceral in
the way that we approach
like it's like the last show of our
lives you know we do that every night
and i don't know any other way to do it
you know and matt doesn't and
christopher we're just like
you know a few wild animals up there
you know is it do you feel it do you
feel
frustration that
you i mean are you gonna do you don't
have a live
album no we don't are you gonna do that
do you think it would get it done do you
think you'd be able to capture it
i think so i think we could uh i mean
the hardest part is really
acoustic guitar live is a difficult
thing to kind of capture that
make that sound like an acoustic guitar
but uh
yeah i think we could capture it live we
should we people ask that all the time
because it is such a different animal i
mean i think
i mean it's a high compliment when
people are like oh it's better than the
albums you know
it's it's uh i think it's more of an
experience i mean
to get people during parts of the show
that
you know the people want to fight during
this time people are crying
you know and you'll see right you see
like a military guy
in a and a [__] hippie in there and
you know and then some guy from some
other completely different background
but somehow they found this secret band
you know that's like this is our band
this is our my band but oh it's success
man too but that's okay well [__] it
we're in this together we're bros
bikers hippies surfers i mean it's like
let's all let's all go get some
right that's freaking yeah i know it's
it's awesome if people get a chance to
see that
it's like um yeah you you got to go
check it out
uh dude
what's the matador about the matador
yeah
matadors or that was actually the first
song they used on sons of anarchy
um that but it was off of my first ep it
was already recorded
uh matador i wanted to do a song
that you couldn't tell if it was a man
um killing people or a man killing
or matador and
i just like that kind of loose um
a thing where you can't tell really and
i i
want to leave it up to the listener
whether they decide is this a man
killing
people in the light of day in public in
front of people
or is this the or is he talking about a
bull fighter yeah
you know that's kind of a wild concept
kind of and i don't know where they
right
how about carnage carnage is another
dark one
um that one my idea was
um some kind of warfare comes to where
you live some kind of
either either it's nuclear viral or
something and you have to take your
family and go hide down in the basement
and it's a kind of a narrative so it
starts and we all just go hide down in
the basement
and i feel like the main character is
kind of
the father figure and then um
you don't know what's happening outside
everyone's just hiding
and it just gets darker and darker and
and
people start kind of losing their minds
the madman uh madman's just
you're doing all murder songs you know
what uh i just thought to myself i'm
like well that's all murder songs
and you know and like you said earlier
you got the sweetest songs you got the
most romantic songs and
you definitely provided some very nice
evenings
for me and my wife to hang out and have
a very pleasant time
you've also provided me with like nice
soundtracks for the darkness
yeah that i mean i i love that i mean
the thing is i don't know why people
don't dive into the [__] dark side of
the pool you know it's like there's so
much
the jungle podcast but there's so much
you know in on in those shadowy parts
like movies like that and stuff like
that like that's a
powerful primal thing that i think is
cool that
that should be explored i think i'm
lucky that i can sing in the way i can
that i can be tender at some moments
when i
when i love song or i have something
that needs to be and then
on the other side of the hand that to be
more aggressive and loud and
howling um but yeah the madman's another
just serial killer kind of murder song
that it's just like
you can't he's undeniable he's just
all-powerful and he's coming after you
it's just scary
uh you know i never i never
have thought about the fact that you
write murder songs before um
until you said it today i was like oh
yeah that's that's the whole thing
there's a bunch of those murder songs
every album at least has at least one
yeah i mean i'm looking at my list i'm
like oh yeah yeah that's that's oh yeah
oh darling what have i done oh yeah
that's that's an
absolute freak that one's [__]
twisted though totally that one's
that one's about a man who thinks
and i don't even know i come up with
this [__] but like how
who thinks in order to get the affection
of his woman
and that he starts killing people and
collecting
basically collecting these lives and
he's killing these people
as like a sign of like the ultimate gift
to give to this woman kind of
in his mind thinking that she's going
he's going to win his
her affection due to
whatever this illusion
how about the pilot uh the pilot
feels like i love this song uh
the high women by jimmy webb yeah and it
wasn't it wasn't
off that thing but it's it's that one's
just kind of just about
kicking ass kind of like like kicking
ass and taking names
right right is that part yeah that's
part of the pilot
i mean that one's i i like how it starts
you know you start with the pilot and
basically it kind of just
sets up sets a table for just a pilot
and then it goes fighter pilot then it
goes outlaw and then it's just like
town what is it the one yeah kicking us
take a name go town to town killing
dreams
yes
uh man you know you did the the album
with the joey white theme throughout it
and that's so that's
that's like a what is it a rock opera
what is it is it a concept album i guess
is what we call it yeah
we've got this whole story this whole
thread of
[Music]
of a couple yeah right and
you know it sounds like they meet when
they're young you've got some freaking
great
lines man just great great stuff
what made you decide to go hey i'm going
concept album
i've always wanted to i mean i always
look at my songs as little movies
little mini movies and the idea of
building a whole narrative
um around those linking those also it's
it's a linear thing which i don't even
know most concept albums are
seem really loose like even if you
listen to the dark side of the moon or
something that's not like you jump from
one thing to
another you know and that's this guy's
whole road
i i did i don't know i've always been
fascinated by
war and soldiers and people going off to
war and then coming back and all this
thing and so
i had some songs already and i was like
i want to do a concept album and then i
said oh and i do it now and i thought oh
i could put this song here
or this can i start changing names put
this song over here and then
build this whole arc of this guy's
lifetime you know it's basically a love
story or
i think it's a love story but it's you
know it's a white buffalo kind of way
right
in a murderous sort of way a dark a dark
thing so they start off they meet each
other
they fall in love but it's kind of this
forbidden love and so they have to go
leave the small town they're from and
he finds out pretty quickly that he
cannot
provide for his family so he joins the
military
goes off to war or kills feels like kind
of a killing machine and then comes back
still kind of bloodthirsty and and
and not assimilating kills again
at home and and then it's
skews back into a love story kind of or
at least this his road to redemption
kind of
and the idea that and the one thing is
the power of love or the power of his
woman
is what makes him feel human or halfway
human again
and um it basically goes the whole arc
to his life at the end he's he's gonna
die and he's kind of questioning god and
and wondering after all this bad [__]
i've done in my life like
am i am i in there are you up there you
know just still kind of
confused and conflicted but
trying to figure out
man freaking all all this great stuff
man
wherever you're getting it from i hope
those little magic nuggets that go into
your brain help or
enter your brain or are produced in your
brain i hope they just freaking keep on
coming man
um hey did your son play lead guitar for
you one time at house of blues he did
many times
okay well i mean my oldest son tanner
um who is we've tried to add a fourth
guy sometimes you know
we've always liked this power trio kind
of thing or with an acoustic guitar is
ridiculous really
but uh um we would try to add a fourth
guy but it
always felt like it kind of took away
from i mean all we were kind of dynamics
you know so we get really big and we get
really quiet we get really big and
with three that seems to work really
well and you add another thing but
tanner is when he's at his
on his game and at his best has been
maybe my favorite fourth
kind of member during it yeah he's an
animal
right on what so what's what's up next
what's the future hold that's a weird
time i mean you know it's like
i had an album coming come out during
this you know
the covid and the pandemic and and
touring stopped we had
i mean a shitload of shows you know
shows going
all of 2020 um
and beyond you know we're gonna go all
the way around the world all over the
world you know at least places that we'd
have some history
and it's just that just i'll stop that
all dried up and so there's nothing
that's all being postponed to hopefully
when we do it i mean our first tour that
we were gonna do in april that's
gonna be a whole year we're gonna go
back to europe in april and then
hopefully stuff will start opening up
and i don't know really
the future is is a
is uh unknown for sure to say the least
but uh
yeah i mean i'm gonna continue i was
really proud of this this you know
recent piece of work that i did
um which almost was going to start out
as a concept as well
what was the concept going to be this
one was one time we were we're touring
traveling we're on like the eastern
seaboard and i keep seeing these uh
these uh rooftop decks up on top of
these kind of victorian houses and i'm
like
what are those you know and and the
drummer was like oh those are called
widows walks
and those are the wives or significant
others of
captains and uh whatever fisherman
whalers or stuff would
you know they would their husbands would
leave and
and go do their jobs but not return for
many months or
many weeks and the wives would go up
kind of
scouting looking longing for their
husbands to come home
and i just thought like oh that's you
got it it's all right there
right i mean you have the romance you
have the drama you have the
to see the power you know and um
just the story was already there i was
like oh it's gonna be easy and so i
started
writing some of those which there's a
song called widow's walk there's another
one with sycamore that made the album
there's a couple that are still on there
but then i had these other songs that i
was like
because it's confining you know if
you're like especially when i think of a
concept
as a narrative to be like oh well
there's this song about
the fires in california in 2018 or there
this song about that
wouldn't really fit in the construct of
that um
so i kind of abandoned the idea without
not entirely kind of some of the songs
made it and then inadvertently
other songs would have other
angles angles and concepts and water and
uh uh longing and lost loves and all
kinds of stuff that
ended up kind of getting into there and
and being part of the writing
but way looser you know
well it's a freaking it's another
another great album and i always talk
about there's
there's not too many bands in my opinion
that can do five awesome albums in a row
like black sabbath they did it
zeppelin they did it metallica close but
they did it
right there's not too many bands that
can do five
awesome albums in a row and part of it
is i think what you said earlier you
know
you're at this level where you know if
if you would have
done that first demo and gotten picked
up by whatever big record company and
had a big bus and all this nice stuff
and
you probably didn't you probably don't
squeeze out even two more good albums
but man you were there and and you're
knocking out every album that you
don't know what number you're on right
now but it's it's more than five and
you're still
freaking putting out awesome work and
i don't know what the future holds but i
do know this when you're back on the
road
we will be there well thank you kindly
you got the uh any last thoughts man
no i just appreciate you i appreciate
you you know
i appreciate that i'm a part of so many
people's lives and
often though than terrible parts of
their lives that that i get people
coming up to me
uh saying how i helped them through this
moment of divorce or
or or being in the military or death of
somebody super close to them
um and i'm proud to be that
you know for a while it's odd because
i'm actually not that
serious of a dude you know i'm pretty
like if you went drinking with me you're
like
that guy really you know and then
but there's like a i guess there's like
a jaclyn hyde thing right it kind of is
if you might do these
silly episodes these things call in the
garage and everything that [__] yeah so
i do it's just me in my garage and i
make some stupid entrance or i'm
spinning and twirling or something and
then
i kind of [__] for two three five
minutes
about nothing i'm just kind of rambling
and then
but it's kind of comedic and then then i
just go into something probably dark and
heavy some song that i have that's in my
catalog and i'll play a song and then
that's it
but it is kind of the duality of my
persona or my
not my persona just who i am that
there's
but it's just like everything i suppose
there's you know laughter and there's
love and there's you know different
sides of the coin
there's the light and the dark and so i
have that i explore that and i explore
that
in music as well well thanks for taking
us on the road with you down that
down that path like i said look i know
i'm coming out dark
cause that's sort of that's sort of
where i tend to go but man there's you
know
a bunch of beautiful songs on there um
the best music for you can apply to
just about every part of your life so
thanks for coming on man
freaking awesome thank you for having me
do you think maybe take it out with
one moa jam [__] you got it
something off the new album yeah this is
not the new album this one's called no
history
yeah um get some
i threw my dreams and wishing well
it seems they all get lost in time
time don't fight fair it's simply
unaware write myself a different story
one that's filled with twisting turns
and life is on fire
where i might get burned
off to a lesson learned i
feel in the future comes
that there won't be love
for everyone
you can't hold the hands of time
[Music]
it's only here and now nothing
way to be more no history
no history
[Music]
[Applause]
memories they come crashing in
living in the past is a waste of your
life
you can't rewind
leave it all behind what if morning
never comes
build your tomorrow's out a day
they're all gonna go
when nobody knows
i feel when the future comes
that
[Music]
no
no history
[Music]
well you can't hold the hands of time
it's only here and now
no history
boom awesome man thanks for coming down
brother my pleasure thank you for having
me
and with that jake the white buffalo
smith
has left the building by the way i
forgot to mention this you can find him
on the interwebs
at thewhitebuffalo.com on facebook at
the white buffalo instagram
buffalo co buffalo
i'm sorry maybe crazy buffalo is it
i think you're b-u-f-f-a-l-o-c-o
buffalo yes twitter
blanco buffalo right so
and then youtube and there's also
youtube channel the white buffalo he
puts out those little videos he was
talking about
that's that man um awesome to have him
down
jake thanks for coming down and echo yes
sir
there is some darkness yeah
and some light in the world it is true
i think uh it was interesting to come
and bring you know for
for those of us that didn't go deep
because you mentioned white buffalo
a lot the buffalo blanco
you mentioned them yeah from time to
time so those of us that didn't go deep
into
you know recently exploring like who
this was that you'd mentioned from time
to time
it was it was good to kind of bring them
to light i understand now
yeah kind of recognize it i recognize i
kind of recognize don't you
yeah at what point at what point did you
go down
before we started recording and he was
sorted sorting out his little
yeah i was like okay actually when he
rolled in and you know when someone
starts talking especially a big guy like
him
i think they start talking like oh you
have a singing voice right now
maybe i noticed that you know why though
i think because you know
like i used to when i used to make like
more
um like how should i say like narrative
type videos and i i yes i would hire a
lot of voice over people
and i did some voiceovers
for echo charles sure yes so a lot of
these
professional voice over people like that
you listen to their demo
or some some of the guys like i'd call
up on the phone and when they answer the
phone i'm like
i i see what you're working with there
already just them talking one guy one
guy was like
he put it on you could tell he put it on
to answer them
and you're like yeah i'm looking for um
mike jacobs the
uh voice actor and he's like one second
please
hello yeah
actually that's essentially what
happened except he just wit
out the gate he was he was performing
right he was okay
he was uh auditioning straight out on
his own but the thing is i emailed him
so he knew i was gonna call so of course
but nonetheless when i heard jake talk i
was like oh i did hit me
like oh okay i see you um and then got
some pipes
yes sir and then that's why i was gonna
ask him like so he you didn't take any
voice
lessons or anything but you just got the
got the talent
yeah out of the gate it's good um
so uh yes so is that that point
i think is when it started to hit me and
then yeah the first song
was really really good and then the
second song was really really good
that's that's just the absolute tip of
the iceberg man they're
gold all throughout those albums man
yeah legit
i'm looking into it well there's
darkness in the world as we heard
yes it's true also some light yes
we talk about the darkness but we want
to move towards the light what do you
got how can we move towards the light
yes always
be moving towards the light you got to
embrace the darkness every once in a
while
but at the end of the day you don't want
to just hang out in darkness the whole
time that's why we're writing songs
called
carnage
[Music]
check and so what are we doing keeping
ourselves capable
as opposed to incapable we are keeping
ourselves healthy
which allows us to be capable which
allows us
to get out of the darkness if need be so
this is what we're doing we're working
out
we're reading you read a lot
i read way more than i did before who
was i just talking to you
somebody i think it's daryl cooper about
like bro i didn't
grow up just oh there's a book let me
start reading books
yeah but now i'm sort of like that like
oh that looks
like yeah well he said where'd you grow
up and you said kawaii he said i
wouldn't have read either if i grew up
in kauai
more stuff to do which that was a good
point for sure
not that san diego sucks though i think
i'm just more mature and understand the
value more
you know how like when you read a lot of
times it's like i'm reading you know
i guess as far as as far as reading goes
anyway
we're doing a lot of stuff to keep
ourselves capable look through okay
let's go back to working out through
workouts
our bodies take a beating that's the
nature of working out really true you
work out take a beating
true then you recover from that beating
those are called gains
and we want to perpetuate gains but you
got to perpetuate beatings as well so
through the beatings are the darkness
the gains are the last are the light
exactly right
exactly exactly right anyway so your
joints will take a beating so
no worries we got some good
supplementation for those joints and for
other stuff so
jocko fuel this is a line high quality
tip top top tier
quality supplementation anyway
joint warfare joints keep your
keep your joints in the game 100 super
krill oil
same deal some antioxidants in there too
super healthy for it's just a healthy
situation the grill oil vitamin d and
i'm going down the line not in
particular order i'm going
down the line in the order that i take
them straight up every single morning by
the way i'm back on the discipline
um disciplined routine thanks for the
suggestion to you by the way
unless okay vitamin d uh immunity keep
the immunity up also
cold war for immunity these are
critical in staying in the game and if
you don't believe me try
not take them i don't try and not take
them but i'm just saying
theoretically if you want to test echo's
theories
yeah go ahead and try it we don't
recommend it yeah
especially if you took them for a long
time then stop taking them that's when
you get you see
you know it's kind of like it's kind of
like if you stop drinking
if you've been drinking for a long time
you stop drinking how like how much
energy you have the next day it's kind
of like that
i mean you know in a matter of speaking
anyway you know what i'm talking about
also discipline the supplement
okay it's like a whole thing it is
multiple choices
yes multiple choice wait what is
discipline yes because you can have
discipline
pills capsules so you can have
discipline powder and you can have
discipline in the cans
yes the whole line of discipline is true
and
i it sorted itself out and it makes
sense to be like okay so this one powder
i take pretty much every day
pretty much take it before workout
that's mainly the thing but if i don't
work out that day just take it in the
morning boom kind of get off to a good
sort of start you know um
the can i use it as essentially an
energy drink
except for you don't feel like junk yeah
and it's like more refreshing than an
energy drink so it's kind of like a
like a i don't know a refreshing energy
drink
okay multiple flavors by the way um and
then the pills that's sort of like
on the go i only took the pills one time
really yeah it
doesn't take in the bills many times
yeah it hasn't rolled into my routine as
uh
seamlessly as maybe in your situation
nice to get that little
hitter yep it's true it's nice to get
that little hater boy
i i would imagine so yes but jock a
white tee we got that as well we also
got molk so
look you need supplementation we talked
about we talked about
the gains being the light well you need
something to build the light with
that's true from a physics point of view
when you want to make gains you need
protein
you might as well protein that tastes
like a dessert that's true
get yourself some milk yeah it's true so
my son
he's four he'll be for this month
goes into the closet this was not
yesterday the day before day before
yesterday it goes into the closet gets
uh the peanut butter
mulk not the kid don't wear your kid one
and he says
can we make some milkshakes straight up
isn't it awesome that your son wants
something as
much as you want him to have it yes here
go like
how often you get to say to your kid yes
they're begging you
to do something that's going to make
them healthier stronger and a better
person
yeah exactly right go have some milk
i'll make it i'll make all the monk you
want how's that sound
yeah perfect it's like them asking you
hey can i go outside and do some
push-ups like do you mind if i do that
do you mind if i go outside and do a
bunch of eight-count bodybuilders just
to get some
and you're like absolutely well can i
have some monkey yes you can
it's the same mix it up for you let me
throw it in the blender throw it in the
shaker
and just make one up for you yeah
exactly right
it's like okay you know how we play you
know where we want to be playing we want
to be playing the long game
right strategic over tactical yes
so every once in a while and i've said
this before it's true
every once in a while you get one of
those golden
diamond nuggets that is
beneficial short term and long term
they're rare they're not every day
they're not every day at every corner
they're not
they're rare but they're there molk is
one of them straight up one of them
salmon sashimi is another one that's my
opinion
white tea did we say chocolate oh you
mentioned it sure certified organic
uh refreshing jock white tea in the tea
bags and in cans too
by the way my wife is on those on that
kick still
for the last like you get this stuff at
origin maine.com or you can get at the
vitamin shop around the corner
yes the vitamin shop around the corner
you have to wait
go get some it's true speaking of origin
main.com other stuff on there
notably jeans american-made denim
straight up from the fabric that is
fabricated
jeans are available t-shirts are
available
these are available
rash guards are available anything that
you basically need to cover your body
boots you need to cover your body
otherwise it's going to get
scraped it's going to get cold and
you're going to be naked yeah
which is not good in many cases in most
cases so get some clothes
get some american-made clothes get some
american-made clothes
that are functional functional and
that's where my judgment stops you have
to judge the other part
speaking of clothes and representing and
wearing things
jocko has a store straight up represent
on the path t-shirts discipline
discipline equals freedom
and it does by the way in case you
didn't know
shirts hoodies
hats beanies you know what else
hardcore recondo t-shirts hardcore condo
t-shirts yeah one of a kind
that i happen to be wearing right now
i'm wearing right now totally legit
oh big time i i haven't i got just got
this what a week ago
yeah and so i've worn it maybe
two three times two of which we were
recording not going
i don't really go out in public that
much but no one's recognized
it when you go well you know
the moment someone recognizes this shirt
that's going to be a level of respect
that's a little bit above the normal
level of respect you got to be
you got to be in the game and on the
path yes sir to get on board with that
also what else on there uh anyway a lot
of good stuff um
i was going to mention yes shorts
board shorts functional i'm going to do
a whole thing i
might even make a video about the shorts
because they're good they're functional
and look good
and they're like double functional board
shorts
they are you should that sounds like a
marketing campaign double phone double
functional they are
this week you can nonetheless get some
warrior kids soap there right yes sir
there you can
warrior kids so go get some of that also
uh subscribe to this podcast if you
haven't yet
which if you haven't yet maybe you
shouldn't maybe you should just move on
with your life
i don't know leave a review
whatever we also have some other podcast
we have the jocko unraveling podcast
which used to be called the thread
it's back it's in its full glory we have
we we re-released or we
are re-releasing the threads that were
removed
now we have the unraveling we have some
new unravelings
coming right now they're out
yeah grounded podcast haven't done one
of those in a little while
we owe you warrior kid podcast
haven't done one of those well we owe
you but
you know there's a lot of lessons you
need to hear multiple times kids
so jump on them we also have a youtube
channel where echo takes
and he he enhances some videos
especially if it's a video that's very
short and you could easily pay attention
to
then he puts a bunch of enhancement in
there to make sure you can watch it for
two minutes and 30 seconds
but when he does a three-hour video he
doesn't put any enhancements in there
it's just a plain black and white video
of two heads or three heads people
talking yeah and for some reason
that's the way eccles organized it which
is his call you know but if you want to
see
what jake smith the white buffalo looks
like if you want to figure out why they
call him the white buffalo
because he kind of represents that yeah
in a visual kind of way sir oh yeah
come and check it out subscribe to the
youtube to the youtube channel
hit like smash the like button
i don't think people i wore out that
joke a few months ago what the smash the
like button
smash the subscribe yeah like comment
and subscribe
okay that's so weird yeah there's
there's a new one out there
uh is there a new way of saying it a new
trend
they say hit the like button and leave a
comment to help out the algorithm
something along those lines because
there's like an algorithm that if it has
likes and
inner engagement or whatever
interactions or whatever it's sort of
like oh this is a significant video
so let's sort of sort of push it or
whatever okay
we're not doing this big campaign to get
you to fix the algorithm
you know what if you like the videos
watch them
subscribe to the youtube channel check
it out that way echo can get in your
head
with his little videos yeah
it won't be me getting in your head
though obviously
i know i think we know [__] and who said
nonetheless yes
youtube video version all good people
are agreeing with me i think you don't
put effects on a
podcast or on this particular podcast
i'm not talking a massive i'm talking an
occasional little easter egg rolling in
maybe if something blows up over there
maybe there's smoke
maybe there's smoke all right some smoke
coming out of jake's guitar
oh yeah you see what i'm saying yeah
okay actually that's there's one thing
that doesn't need it effects it's jake
yeah didn't need an effects today it
could be cool though i don't know jury
still
nonetheless yes youtube also
psychological warfare it's an
album not like white buffalo album
no different more like
well we'll just call it psychological
warfare for now so what it is it's a
spoken word
album yes spoken word yeah and those
words are speaking to you
on your moments of weakness so if you're
about to skip the workout
but i came close to skipping workout 2
by the way
yesterday that's why you're looking
skinny
[Music]
while we're doing this right now do you
think everyone's annoyed or you think
it's just me
it's very possible yeah it's very
possible everyone's annoyed
but nonetheless i think this is a a
moment of value
in my opinion okay i was about to skip
the workout i've listened this i didn't
listen to psychological warfare
so yesterday you know why i didn't have
to i listened to it so many times
before when i really needed it that it
was like
it was sort of in the rolodex back there
sort of plain
so i listened to it virtually in my mind
and you did the workout did the workout
straight up that's awesome man good job
[Music]
i do play that game that one that you
play or
we were talking about that it's like hey
if you have those moments of like
oh yeah like man i really should hurry
up and get to what i was gonna do
you know anything any excuse you come up
with your head that you're going to skip
the last part of the workout of the
workout you punish yourself with extra
work yeah you know
for even thinking that i play that game
check also if you want to have a visual
representation to kind of keep you
squared away go to flipsidecanvas.com by
my brother dakota meyer making cool
graphical art to hang on your wall
graphical sure graphical also
uh you know pick up some of jake's music
you know go
download the music or order it or
whatever
um however you're gonna get that music
go get it man go get it
jake's out there making it happen also
got some books
the code the evaluation the protocols
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual warrior kid
one two and three mikey in the dragons
discipline equals freedom field manual
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
pick up some of those books if you like
what we talk about on here
also have a leadership consultancy
called echelon front if you need help
with leadership inside your organization
go to echelonfront.com
if you want to get engaged in the online
brigade that we have
where i talk about leadership i interact
you want to ask me a question
you're thinking oh i wish i could ask
jack a question
you can you can literally come on there
and ask me a question
doing two to three times a week i'm on
there
live interaction go to efonline.com
leadership is not something that you
just get and now you're good and you
know what maybe you don't maybe you want
to ask me about jiu jitsu maybe you want
to ask me about some relationship that
you're in
whatever you want to ask me come and ask
me
efonline.com we have the muster
the next muster is in phoenix arizona
september 16th and
17th then we're gonna be in dallas texas
december third and fourth go to extreme
ownership.com
for details we've sold out all these
things that we've done these ones are
less seating because of social
distancing
so they're going to sell out even
quicker we have ef overwatch
if you need leadership inside your
organization you want experience
leadership go to efoverwatch.com where
we have
candidates that are proven leaders from
the military that understand the
principles we talk about
go there and hire someone eforewatch.com
we also have america's
mightywarriors.org
that is mama lee mark lee's mom
who is on a mission to do good
to help service members to help their
families to help gold star families to
help people that are deployed around the
world if you want to get involved or
donate go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you enjoy overdoing things
and you want to hear my more of my
conspicuous questions or you feel like
you just can't live without
a little bit more of echo's illogical
inquiries that you can find us
on the interwebs on twitter on instagram
and on the facebook echo is that echo
charles and i am at jocko willing and
jake the white buffalo can be found on
the interwebs at thewipebuffalo.com
facebook the white buffalo instagram
buffalo co
twitter blanco buffalo and his youtube
channel
is the white buffalo and thanks again
to jake for coming on the show for
sharing your vision your voice with us
thanks for taking care of our veterans
and thanks for adding a soundtrack to my
life and to all
the veterans out there thanks for
stepping up into
the madness into the darkness
and thanks for not backing down into the
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service and
all the first responders out there
thanks for keeping the darkness at bay
on the home front
and everyone else out there the words
from a white buffalo song called when
i'm gone
he says i feel it closing in on me i got
to be
all i can be in this life there ain't no
guarantee
you don't get no [__] for free
what does that mean it means you gotta
get out there
and get after it and until next time
this is echo
and jocko out